you want a high floor a luxurious pool a
cool breeze off both balconies but most
of all you want a luxury hotel that will
violently fight infidels introducing the
Nina hua international hotel of Mosel
presented by Isis first a welcoming
smile a check-in then a warm chocolate
chip cookie then you'll swear at
gunpoint to support our cause whatever
it is when you get to your room you're
gonna want to kick off those shoes and
enjoy a wide selection of movies on
demand lay by the pool and relax to the
sounds of Mosel at night enjoy nightlife
at the four-star Isis Bar and Grill but
no drinking alcohol smoking gambling or
dancing silly you've got a presentation
tomorrow
and besides we'll beat you to your the
color of a plum the ISIS hotel because
luxury is knowing you can be yourself
unless you're like a woman with ideas a
homosexual a blasphemer a cartoonist any
sort of American French or British
national bisexual transgendered vegan
Shia Kurd moderate Sunnis definitely not
Jewish from America the European Union
or its allies the government of Iran
Iraq Syria Turkey or Saudi Arabia Rick
Santorum Mike Huckabee Carly Fiorina ben
Carson Hillary Clinton Beyonce Rihanna
Lady Gaga Brian Williams but L nobody
wants him a birthday party clown or
anyone associated with any of the above
so Booker's summer vacation today at the
Nina WA International Hotel of Mosel
presented by Isis were always ahead of
the game
[Music]